all right guys bang-bang I've got Matt
here with me I feel like we are deep
into the quarantine got the quarantine
beards no haircuts just ready to rock
and roll Matt I appreciate jumping on
and recording this and short notice
yeah absolutely thanks for having me Tom
for sure let's just jump right in
let's go over your background and that
we can get into other recent report you
guys cranked out yeah so I you know I
started getting involved in digital
currency space in 2015 with one of my
partners I launched the digital currency
hedge fund in 2017 called washing
Opportunity Fund we still manage that
more liquid assets and then in late 2017
my brother's college roommate saw an
opportunity on the mining side there was
a there's an arbitrage for mining rigs
between the US and China and together we
launched blocker solutions we've now
become one of the largest distributors
of Asics to the US market over the past
year we've sold about 30,000 basics to
the US market we place miners in
colocation facilities we do research
we've got a Bitcoin pool and now we're
really building on our research arm to
educate the market in the US you know
our goal is to have bring as much hash
to the US because we need this
decentralized Network we can't have 65%
of the hash in China so in January with
another partner Mike Stelzner we
launched the Bitcoin fund call block
remaining and we're mining Bitcoin in
Kentucky I've got about we'll have about
180 peda hash by the end of the week
we've got 500 those s17 pluses coming
online and what we're doing is we're
offering a turnkey solution to u.s.
miners so that they can get up and hash
it immediately they have a great site on
with exceptional technologists managing
the site so with that we we deeply
understand the Bitcoin network
we've got a large we have we've you know
we've we visited sites in Chengdu
China on the Pacific Northwest upstate
New York and that allows us to deeply
understand the network what electricity
rates are at all around the world whose
mine in and what mining rigs are they
running are they writing old gen
technology or new gen and what that does
is that allows us to understand the
break-even prices of all these different
miners across the globe Blocker
solutions I mean we service people in in
china russia mongolia we have we have
either partners or or other you know
service providers all over europe even
even South America Mexico North America
so that gives us communicating with all
them it gives us a very good feel of
what electricity rates are and what type
of technology miners are running and
through that we can estimate and
understand what different miners
breakeven prices are now many analysts
have have said that the cost of
production for a miner is is price
support when you read our research
report you'll see that it's not price
support for Bitcoin it actually
accelerates sell-offs in in the price of
Bitcoin the key the key expense or
variable for miners is their electricity
about ninety-five percent of their
operational expenditure is electricity
so if you're at a electricity rate of
six cents and you're running a hundred
machines and someone has an electricity
rate of four sons and they're running a
hundred machines you're you're you're
running at a 50% greater breakeven than
the individual with four cents so when
the miners when the miners had six sons
they start approaching one Bitcoin
starts approaching the break-even price
price of a miner at six cents their
margins become compressed they're there
their net profitability decreases and
they have to sell more of that Bitcoin
there you know the revenue is coming in
as Bitcoin and as that margin
compression happens they have to sell
more Bitcoin so one now when a miner
goes under the break-even price now
have to pull Bitcoin from their Treasury
and sell that to fund their electricity
every month you have to pay for that
electricity and that's what's creating
salt pressure on the network there's
really three participants in in the
Bitcoin network
there's the investment funds there's the
hot lers and there's the miners all
three for the most part are very bullish
on most funds most most most hollers
they're long only but miners they're
truly the most bullish because they're
buying mining rigs and they're building
out facilities assets with three to five
year life cycles um we're if you're fun
you can risk manage I mean you can buy
five million ten million worth of
Bitcoin and be bullish but tomorrow you
can sell out of it right miners are
stuck there they are they are the
ultimate call option so they you know
they're they're mining their Bitcoin and
they have to fund their electricity bill
every day there's about 1800 Bitcoin
released every month it's fifty four
thousand Bitcoin when Bitcoin was at ten
thousand that was a half a billion of
new of new Bitcoin released onto the
market every month two miners that is
potential sell pressure now they're not
selling at all but when Bitcoin starts
to sell off and these inefficient miners
have to sell their Bitcoin to to to
saman to support their electricity bill
that exacerbates sell sell sell off some
nickel it so you know we saw that bit
max the bit max blow up where Bitcoin
you know it it it wick down from you
know about 7800 all the way to maybe
3,800 there was only strong hands left
right anyone else who was holding the
Bitcoin that's a lot of strong hands but
we've we've we've had difficulty
rallying I mean I think overall the
overarching theme is the US equity
market and then the global macro but
overall yes a lot of holders blew out
but we still have this cell pressure
from miners and I think that's creating
price drag right now because these
miners still have to fund electricity
they have to do some type of treasury
management
so they're selling their Bitcoin
everyday to have cash so that they can
fund their electricity bill now these
things are this is how this is just how
the Bitcoin network works and it's it's
healthy it's it's a self-correcting
mechanism as as as these inefficient
miners blow out you know we we model the
network in eight layers on layer one
being miners with two and a half cent
electricity or lower layer two being
three sons four cents five five point
five six cents six-and-a-half and then
seven cents are above so that's that's
the layers then we broke that down
further into who's running old gen verse
who's running next gen now this is
what's really interesting we've had this
hardware upgrade cycle in 2019 it main
relaized all these seven nanometer chips
so miners who are running at seven cents
and bought the new technology since the
machines are so efficient their
breakeven price is lower than a miner at
three cents running the old gen so about
45% about probably thirty five to forty
percent of the network is still old gen
and now because of the hardware upgrade
cycle we had in 2019 and still occurring
about sixty sixty-five percent is next
gen these these miners at seven cents
which is quite high running next gen
equipments have a lower break-even price
than these miners in China with three
cents running old gen equipment and that
has changed up the game and that's gonna
keep more cell pressure on the network
for what we believe to be another three
to four months I'll go into our later
thesis of what we think is going to
happen
it's very bullish but you know we're
gonna go through a cycle of my you know
minor capitulation and and and that's
ultimately gonna position us for our
next leg up because once you get these
inefficient miners out of the network
who are creating the cell pressure
that's how you position to rally next
so we just got a taste of it you know
last week we had one of the largest
difficulty adjustments in bitcoins
history and we were monitoring the pools
we saw a lot of the Asian pools lose
more hash than some of the American
pools so tall as that signal of you know
miners in the East that that are running
old gen technology they're probably the
ones that were shutting off and and and
that's that's a really healthy thing for
the network you know it's it's it when
we go through having having is very
bullish because ultimately half the
potential sell pressure gets removed and
and these inefficient miners are gonna
have to shut off now when they shut off
difficulty adjust the most I think the
the least one at least understood and
the and and and under respected
attributes of the Bitcoin network is
difficulty I I can't believe I just
don't understand how Satoshi did it in
in in 2009 or 2010 and because it's a
self-correcting mechanism you know right
now in the world we have this monetary
policy where central bankers can just
print and manipulate in the Bitcoin
network everything is controlled by code
the monetary policy is controlled by
cold code and when people become
inefficient they shut off and difficulty
adjusts and the rewards that the people
that shut off the miners that shut off
their Bitcoin starts getting allocated
to whoever less and their margins the
miners at last their margins improve
because they're getting more Bitcoin and
they're able to secure the network it's
it's it's like a gravity difficulty is
like a gravity if if too many miners
come online then bitcoin is getting
distributed to several miners and
everyone has miner compression these
inefficient miners at the higher layers
they blow out difficulty adjusts and
bitcoin starts getting
allocated to the miners that still
survive and then their margins normalize
and it goes the other way so so it's
it's it's a very interesting mechanism
and it's self-correcting there isn't
manipulation and and that kind of goes
in our later thesis which we can talk
about which i think is going to be very
attractive for people especially with
what's going on in the global macro yes
so one of the things i want to touch on
is this whole idea of there's tons of
miners who are mining but they don't
sell 100% of the Bitcoin to pay for
electricity do you have any sense of the
percentages that certain miners are
having to sell and then how that changes
with price fluctuations as well right
are there certain kind of in those tiers
you described some that to sell 100% to
fund operations and some that are maybe
selling only 10% and then if you kind of
back into the larger miners probably
have lower cost power you can really
start to understand how much of the cell
pressure on a daily basis is coming from
miners or is that just too many unknown
variables and therefore difficult to to
come up with right now no that's a great
question in our report we model all that
out we have these large tables of the
research report these Excel tables and
that's exactly what we're doing we
understand how much electricity is being
consumed by each layer based on their
margins so if you're running a 17 and at
6 cents you might be consuming $80 worth
of electricity per month and you may be
making 120 in revenue so you know that
you have to sell $80 of your 120 which
is at least 7075 percent right no 66%
right so their margins are 33 percent
and they have to sell 66 percent of
their electricity if they're at for
example six cents and then if they're
had five sons maybe they only have to
solve 50% and if there are three sons
they only have to sell thirty percent
and that's that's what's key and you
know you brought that up and that's
what's so helpful for the network when
these when these miners who
our operating almost at breakeven and
have to sell 80 to 100 percent of their
Bitcoin blowout and now their Bitcoin is
getting allocated to these efficient
miners who only have to sell 30% while
they're holding more Bitcoin cell
pressure comes off the network um you
know people a lot of people think that
Bitcoin trades a couple billion a day
that's what's important
that's inaccurate a majority of that is
fake Asian training
it's algos it's it's day trading that
just creates short-term volatility what
moves the price of of an asset is net
fiat in and net fiat out and that's what
and and we're interested in the
intermediate it's a long term right so
I'm interested in what's in that money
in net money out miners are bringing net
money out because they they're getting
your Bitcoin and they're selling it to
fund electricity now demand and positive
sentiment is what brings funds and
Hodler is to bring new cash in and we
think and and that counterbalance is
miners sell pressure now that miners
cell pressure will get reduced when
inefficient miners are operating at
their breakeven or below breakeven they
have to shut off and now their Bitcoin
is going to the miners who only have to
sell 10 or 20% of their Bitcoin to fund
electricity and that's how you get these
better environments for Bitcoin of rally
we're gonna experience that we just got
a taste we just had that large
difficulty adjustment that was a bunch
of old generation equipment getting
wiped out once we go through the having
revenue is gonna get cut in half all the
old generation equipment for the most
part is going to shut off you know
markets most mark markets are supposed
to be one of the most efficient price
discounts in mechanisms right future
discounting mechanisms I think in equity
markets the larger the market the the
more efficient right crypto markets are
probably one of the less efficient
markets out there but there's there's
still efficiencies so we think we think
we think a lot of the S nines are going
to shut off but some of them are
flow to areas in the world that just had
the cheapest power or subsidized power
it's like pouring a bottle of water at
the top of a mountain it's gonna go to
the lowest point that's it's that's how
that's how gravity and water works these
s nines are gonna flow to areas like
Venezuela they're gonna flow to areas
like Iran Kazakhstan where there's
subsidized power or near zero power or
low flow to areas where where a utility
has excess power and and named Lincoln
they'll be smart enough to get involved
we have clients capturing the natural
gas and they're running at one cent
power that's gonna be a boom in the US
are the group that we're working with is
uh is a steel mill and and and some of
their jobs are getting repurposed to
Bitcoin mining there's I mean I mean the
revolution that's going to happen with
with Bitcoin mining is about power
that's the most important component so
those who have the cheapest power in the
world are going to start getting
involved in this they already are and
then just make their network more
credible and more secure because you
have these you have Bitcoin you know our
belief is Bitcoin is a commodity and
it's infancy and and when you get a
better release of the supply you get
less volatility and it becomes more
usable right and Bitcoin is just it's
it's ten years old it's a it's it's a
commodity in its infancy you look at oil
gold soybeans all the suppliers are
they're the ones controlling the supply
and they kind of influence price
well they hedge out twelve months right
were there futures contracts and they're
and they're forwards
you know Cargill Barrett gold Aramco
they all have twenty man trade desks
hedging out the product with Bitcoin
mining it's a Chinese farmer at some
small farm small farm in the US and and
and when Bitcoin starts to sell off they
might keep their coin and they're
exacerbating the prices in Bitcoin and
they're they're the suppliers so once
this becomes more is
- she lies once we get better products
which is happening right in our face
right see amy has their future now we
have options we're witnessing Bitcoin
becoming more mature and when this
supply gets released smoother and
volatility gets sucked out more it
becomes a better store of value and it
becomes a better digital gold
I mean if oil was just fluctuating like
crazy it is I mean mostly that people
don't realize commodities are some of
the most volatile assets so you want to
point to Bitcoin
talk about volatility I mean oil was at
150 in 2009 2010 and now it's hit $20 so
there you go a lot it's lost 85 percent
right so we think there's a lot of
things that are happening right now that
just make a very bullish Bitcoin to come
out anything is a bit of a tangent but
but Bitcoin is 10 years old it's a
commodity in its infancy the difference
is no matter what the supply gets
released
that's code but but the people that are
going to influence the supply won't
become far far more diligent about how
it's released we're gonna have better
exchanges we're gonna have derivative
products they're gonna start using
better schedules for treasury management
volatility will get sucked out and and
it's going to be a more usable digital
gold because volatility gets sucked out
and and now people are going to use it
for its it and most importantly it's all
happening right in front of our face the
futures market is very robust where
there's so many options yep but one of
things I want to ask about is using this
thesis of kind of the mining cell
pressure walk us through what you expect
to happen over the next you know call 45
days before the having what happens at
the moment of the halving and then maybe
what happens in the three months after
the halving and then kind of 18 months
out so going into the having absolute
having three months after and then 18
months after that yeah so we initially
put this report out to some to our
investors and
in January so we were kind of expecting
the sell-off and we think that bitcoin
is probably in a training range and
it'll continue to stay in quite
compressed margins for miners going in a
habit now once we go through having the
miners revenue is gonna get slashed in
half this is one we're going to
experience what I call you know I think
it's gonna be a healthy cleanse of the
network um we're probably going to
experience difficulty adjustments of if
Bitcoin is still at eight thousand or
lower going into having we're probably
gonna this is one we're gonna get
extreme minor capitulation probably
thirty potentially forty percent of the
network shutting off anyone with power
above two cents running the whole
generation equipment is gonna blow out
miners with mid generation equipment
like TTTS
the in Isola con machines those are
gonna blow out if you're at four cents
or higher and individuals running the
the newest equipment at seven and a half
cents seven cents high sixes they're
gonna have to shut off so I basically
just listed off about 40% of the network
and that's in the report we really lay
all that out now what is that it's not a
light switch people can't just turn off
their machines and they're not going to
just turn off their machines there's
friction you know people want to hope
people are in people have utility
contracts where they have to consume a
certain amount of power otherwise they
they lose their long-term contract they
might be in hosting facilities where if
they default on their payments then
they're they lose their mining rigs so
if you just bought thousands of dollars
worth of mining rigs you're going to
keep paying your bill for two or three
months until you blow out people are in
facilities and they have to pay you know
their lease payments they've built out
all this infrastructure so they're still
mining the rigs and and once there they
started to faulty non runs which might
take two or three months and the
facility kicks them out so we think once
having hits we're going to experience
this massive difficulty of
because inefficient miners are gonna
shut off and we think it could take
maybe May through potentially July of
friction of people shutting off people
wiping out throwing in the towel and
completely shutting off and and that's
when we're gonna actually get difficulty
kicks in and margins are gonna get
better
the efficient miner should not fear have
it they should welcome it their margins
we've analyzed it and we believe that
margins of miners at six cents and lower
right in the most efficient equipment
their margins are going to be about the
same pre having and post habit after all
these miners shut off and it's because
they're gonna get the Bitcoin that so
those miners who are run who shut off
about forty percent of them once they
shut off that bitcoins got to go
somewhere it's going to go to the people
that last mining is about survivability
you just need to survive if you survive
difficulty will adjust in the future and
it's gonna it's going to improve your
margins because the people that are
inefficient their Bitcoin is going to go
to you so what that does is all these
inefficient miners wipe out then we're
operating where eighty percent of their
mind Bitcoin needed to get sold to fund
electricity they're gone
there's we're 50/50 percent there are
only 30 percent of their Bitcoin needs
to get sold
now you've removed not only does having
to remove 50 percent of the potential
salt pressure but now now it's like now
the strongest hands are accumulating
Bitcoin and they have the best mop
trizzie a lot of self pressure is gonna
get removed from the network and that's
how we position to have the next leg up
so it's it's it's going to be
exceptional an exceptional improvement
on the supply set and we think that's
gonna it'll take maybe May through
through July or early August for all
that to kind of shuffle off and it we're
really excited because we layer in the
global macro it's all this we think you
know with with what's going on in the US
if if we have this continued shutdown if
we have a lot of jobs lost you know the
Fed the Fed I think they forgot the
exact number was either two or six
trillion and people look at that and
they think it's the end because the
number is so big it's not about the
number the Fed they operate in cycles
you know it's it's market cycles it's
it's economic cycles when you're
printing its cycles it's it's a process
you don't just inject six trillion and
everything's fixed it's it's going to be
a process of many more injections and
and people aren't just gonna it's not
going to be business as normal once we
get back once we eradicate this disease
people are going to be very cautious
companies are going to be very cautious
with spending and and we think it's
going to take you know a longer recovery
so with that this is what's interesting
many market participants are not going
to like that system of the Fed being
able to just inject money whenever
whenever they'd like to so when you get
when you get a scenario like that you
get market participants that start to
look at other options and if we believe
they're gonna look at Bitcoin as is
parallel financial system where our prep
there the I think a lot of people are
gonna go our present system is broken
you could print as much as you want
buying all types of assets but this
Bitcoin what is this technology it's
dictated by code
the inflation rate is is is fixed and
then it has no one could no one can mess
with that and when you get when you get
speculators when you get a technologist
of technology like Bitcoin that's in
that's in its infancy and now you layer
in a bunch of speculators who start to
imagine and envision the possibilities
of this actually come into fruition I
mean that's what 2020 is doing 2018
invent excuse me it's 2008 spawned
Bitcoin that Bitcoin was invented by
Satoshi because of 2008 2020 I believe
is going to allow speculators to imagine
and envision the possibilities of
Bitcoin actually getting adopted Bitcoin
doesn't have to Bitcoin doesn't have to
get adopted for there to be a bull
market speculators just need a secondary
market with liquidity so the ability to
speculate and they need to they need to
envision the possibilities and imagine
the possibilities and I think that's
what's going to happen I think I think I
think the supply side is going to be
extremely well positioned for Bitcoin
rally because of extreme minor
capitulation that's going to occur from
having and I think that's gonna play out
between you know May through August and
and all this cell pressure will get
removed from the network because the
miners are gonna blow out and and then I
believe the fundamental story is just
improving everyday do do you know what's
going on with a global macro the the
printing and and I believe that's going
to improve the fundamental story it's
gonna it's gonna allow people to say
look at this parallel financial system
we prefer that over over Donald Trump
pressuring Jerome Powell to to print and
and when you get speculators when you
get a technology in its infancy that's
disruptive like Bitcoin you get
speculators starting to imagine and
envision the possibilities of this
technology coming to fruition and you
get a secondary market with liquid
that's how you get a parabolic bull
markets and I think that's what's all
girly right all right so Matt one of the
questions I have for you is obviously
the oil prices have been dropping very
quickly over the last couple of weeks
and we're reaching a point now where
we're going on multiple weeks of that
oil price being below where most oil
producers especially the United States
are not profitable do you see a world
where the folks who have this oil
realize hey rather than just selling the
barrels of oil I can actually use that
to generate power and I should be mining
crypto at a much more profitable manner
or even maybe some of the other excess
power producers kind of going in as well
I'm starting to realize this or do you
think that we're still far away from
what I'll call traditional industry or
traditional energy producers kind of
crossing the chasm into Bitcoin mining
it's you know that's a great question
and it's it's very specific to the US
there's a group I mean there I want to
keep everyone's stuff confidential but
there's a leader that we've done
business with we respect them he's
really intelligent and they're building
us out in in several states they're
capturing the flare gas there I'd say
that the leaders in it and and there's
excess right now so they're going to
these different oil drillers and they're
working with them they're capturing the
flare gas they're using these natural
gas generators and and the power is very
cheap I have another client we just had
a call with them last week it's two two
individuals out west and and they are
doing the same thing to a smaller scale
but they're gonna ramp up because
they've identified the opportunity and
they're gonna capture it they are going
there in there in Texas and they're
capturing the the flare gas they're
connecting it with a natural gas
generator and and they're burning that
and they have one sent electricity it's
this is going to change mining it brings
in it creates cost efficiencies for
these oil you know the the
oil chillers don't have anything to do
with they don't have anything to do with
the natural gas so either burn it or you
know it doesn't it doesn't store well so
that's why they're utilizing it it's
it's it's basically a by-product that's
being leveraged so yeah we see an
opportunity there I'm not as proficient
as explaining that because I'm not doing
it but I have clients that are and
they're making exceptional money doing
it one cent electricity and mining
Bitcoin so there's going to be synergies
where you could where you could bring
Bitcoin mining to these fields put down
a container have the natural gas
generators capture the flare gas burn it
or whatever mechanism it is I'm guessing
the national gas generator does that and
and they're achieving one cent
electricity and that's funny in the
mining rigs and and that's you know it's
it's being very efficient so and we have
a lot of that in the u.s. the US has the
first is the most energy abundant
country in the world I mean we you look
at Texas there's wind power there's
solar there's natural gas oil they have
it all so we're gonna leverage it and
and and and it makes me very very
bullish for Bitcoin yeah so in the US I
mean there's people I think don't
realize there's so much energy abundancy
in the u.s. in Kentucky we're using
hydro there's there's a lot of hydro in
upstate New York Pacific Northwest
you have Texas has wind solar oil
natural gas just about everything so
that's why I mean--but made I don't know
if people know this bit Maine is mining
in Texas so the Chinese are coming here
you have you have all the stability in
the US with regulation the
municipalities just don't shut you down
overnight you don't have to negotiate
with the politicians it's very you know
if you're gonna if you're going to
allocate millions of dollars to a mining
operation you know as
hedge fund manager you want to assure
you can have a grasp of your risk you
don't want to deploy something in China
or Russia and overnight someone shuts
down your mind right in the u.s. you
have that stability and most importantly
you ever done an see the grid when was
the last time we had a blackout in the
US people are deploying stuff in
Venezuela Iran I think 20% of the day
they have blackouts in the US the
bandwidth the internet connectivity
these miners need to be connected at a
hundred percent up times right so in the
US you have a hundred percent off times
in other countries in the internet might
be down for 15 20 percent there in the
year so your couple and all these all
these variables the abundancy of energy
what these miners are doing with the
natural gas the exceptional Internet
connectivity the the regulation and
stability it's just a far healthier
environment to be Bitcoin mining and the
numbers show it and that's why the
acceleration the growing market is North
America and it's exceptional for our for
the Bitcoin network because you want
this decentralization we want more hash
in the US we don't want all the ASIC
manufacturers in China and 65% of the
hash in China and the majority of the
pools in China right
so we want this decentralized network
it's a significant value add and it's
what you know it's part of the you know
the the the fundamentals of a Bitcoin so
it's we're excited we're glad that we're
seeing the acceleration North America as
well what if anything are you seeing on
the central bank's side or kind of a
nation-state side are you seeing any
interest there from countries or
governments themselves um not not yet I
think I think I've seen articles about
like Belarus thinking about getting
involved I think I think the it doesn't
move the needle for them yet you know
country is so large where for them to
take on making 50 million
years something like that I think it
doesn't move the needle for them yet but
but in in five or 10 years if this truly
gets commoditized you got to think that
utility companies are going to be the
big players potentially nation-states
anyone right it's it's a market it's an
efficiency whoever's got the cheap power
the subsidized power the free power the
economics are best for them so whether
they partner with someone who's a
service provider who brings the mining
rigs and run the operation you know
there's some of that going on
I know I know utilities who are starting
to to work with different advisory
services who can who can build this out
or so so there was efficiencies like
that getting created and as Bitcoin as
Bitcoin continues temperature people are
going to feel more comfortable with it
when when fidelity is getting involved
you get better you get better custody
right when you get when you get better
markets then you can rely on you know we
have we have miners who are publicly
traded and and they want to they may
want to use an American mining pool who
you gets like a sack report so that this
publicly traded mining company is more
comfortable with where they're getting
their rewards from so there's there's a
lot of things that could really improve
this industry and bring more
participants in and when you when you
remove that type of friction the
investment dollars come in to fund
managers are more comfortable allocating
capital that's going to be on both sides
right you get a you here's a thing the
economy has gotten a bit rough but but
we're seeing and there's been disruption
everywhere I haven't seen a ton of
disruption in the mining space we're
still we're still selling mining rigs
there's I mean think about how bullish
that is you're you have miners in 40 50
plus countries that are buying
infrastructure dedicated just for
Bitcoin there's been billions of dollars
allocated towards mining bitcoins
securing the network the infrastructure
that's network effects
value I mean that it's not just about
Bitcoin it's not just about the coin
it's about this this network of miners
all around the world they're spending
money on infrastructure they have
conviction they're they're gonna support
the network that's valuable if you want
to shut down the Bitcoin network you got
to go if Donald Trump said I'm shutting
down the Bitcoin network well he's got
to go to China he's got to go to
Venezuela he's got to go to Berlin he's
gotta shut down every single little
minor otherwise the network keeps keep
settling blocks right so so that's the
value of decentralization right there
there's miners all around the world in
in in different sovereign countries that
is very very powerful so you know we're
people people always talk about network
effects I think the biggest network
effect in Bitcoin is the miners and the
billions of dollars that are spending
towards facilities power contracts
mining equipment firmwares there's
there's data centers that are
traditional data centers that are
bringing miners into their in their
facilities that's network effects that
is a healthy network yeah got it
makes a ton of sense before we finish up
I always ask people what's uh what's
your favorite book my favorite book um
probably reminiscence of a stock
operator why that's that was when I you
know when I started getting into
equities my partner who he's so when I I
started getting mentored in equity
markets around 40 or 15 and that was the
first book he referred to me to learn
about equities and that's really what
has kicked off my you know my my career
in the financial services you know
running money thinking about human
psychology
and really thinking about how markets
affect each other how people affect
markets right when I when I discussed
what I think the fundamentals of what's
going on with Kiwi this that
that's a human psychology trade it's
it's it's a bunch of speculators who are
gonna get involved
imagine this disruptive technology
getting adopted and then human
psychology just takes over that's how
you get these bull markets you layer in
that that that's that liquid secondary
market and that's how these things
happen it had it's happened time after
time in history it repeats itself
technology and its infancy that that's
disruptive secondary liquid market
speculators being able to imagine the
possibilities of it coming to fruition
parabolic ball market for sure before I
let you ask me one question to finish up
asks everyone about aliens believer or
non-believer uh yeah I am a believer I
don't I don't know you know I can't
prove it but I think yeah I think it's
out there the world is bigger than us
right maybe they deployed a virus on but
yeah
you never know you never know what one
question you have for me to to finish up
here what are you most excited about in
the Bitcoin space time I think that's
the most important thing is it always
goes back to the Bill Gates quote for me
we overestimate what we can do in one
year and underestimate what we can do in
ten and if you went back to 2009-2010
and told people this is where Bitcoin
would be today I think they would have
told you that you're crazy but if you
ask people you know even this year what
are we gonna do the next twelve months I
think that they'll be overly optimistic
and so for me it's just the passing of
time gives builders the ability to build
that gives investors the ability to kind
of be converted into holders and it
gives time for the infrastructure and
market liquidity to be built out and
then also the education to happen which
i think is all really important for for
the ecosystem and so it's ways things
where if you can remain optimistic
upbeat even through these long bear
markets and kind of downward cycles then
over long periods of time it ends up
working out really well and so I think
just time is and kind of passage of
times the most exciting thing to me
absolutely I mean you're you're rarely
you're rarely gonna find a successful
pessimist you got to stay optimistic so
I completely agree with you absolutely
where can people find you and in the
company online you can go to block or
solutions.com that's that's that's the
company that we're really servicing the
mining network if you want to learn more
reach out I could we could talk about
our other companies as well we've got a
Bitcoin mining pool we've got an
exceptional firmware to get as much
badge for the US miners
we've got mining rigs on site and a
colocation facility in the u.s. so
miners can be up in hashing in within 48
hours
so block we're solution is calm reach
out to us I'm also on Twitter
MJ dis user to reach out to us always
happy to answer questions and put out
the best information we can absolutely
Jo's got you hooked up there with the
Twitter account listen I really
appreciate you doing this Matt I think
that people are really going to enjoy
hearing from you especially around I'm
kind of having and a lot of the miner
cell pressure etc so we'll have to do
this again maybe post having at some
point later this year but I really
appreciate the time to to go over all
this with us absolutely guys and you
know I think I think everyone should
stay positive with what's going on with
the virus it's a great opportunity to
spend time with our friends and family
I've had the pleasure of being able to
have dinner with my family the past
seven days and and I think those are the
most important things so let's
appreciate all that take care guys thank
you got it man